[Musique]
depuis plusieurs semaines je suis venu à
votre rencontre à la rencontre de celles
et ceux qui vivent et font notre région
comme beaucoup d'entre vous je suis dit
si je suis né à marmande dans le
lot-et-garonne
j'ai grandi dans cette région j'ai fondé
une famille j'ai fait mes études je suis
ancré dans ce territoire
je suis élu régional depuis dix ans
comme vous j'aime profondément notre
région
[Musique]
ça fait quelques semaines que gens
parcourent les routes et les chemins que
je vais à la rencontre des néo aquitain
à votre rencontre
je suis venu pour échanger vous écouter
parce qu'elle c'est le sens de mon
engagement
le sens de mon action pensez à vous agir
pour vous
oui
les équipes que j'ai constitué
département par département
elles sont à votre image fait d'élus
locaux de gens investis dans leurs
villages dans leur ville et ils seront
défendre la proximité pour être plus
proche pour travailler ensemble et qu'il
n'y ait pas cet éloignement entre
bordeaux et le reste de cette région
[Musique]
je porte et nous portons les valeurs de
la droite et du centre c'est la
responsabilité c'est le respect de
l'autorité
la campagne électorale nous l'avons
lancée depuis ça rend sur les terres de
jacques chirac
car c'est dans ces packs nous voulons
marcher que nous voulons inscrire notre
action vos préoccupations
je les connais et je les partage tout
doit être mis en oeuvre pour préserver
notre sécurité votre sécurité
c'est l'accès à la santé oms
c'est la sortie crise que nous devons
organiser la formation nos jeunes il
faut leur donner un avenir
le développement des emplois ne pouvons
pas nous résoudre à voir autant de
chômeurs dans ce territoire
la prise en compte des enjeux
environnementaux et énergétiques
c'est aussi la sauvegarde de nos
cultures de notre patrimoine
nous proposons d'agir vite et fort sur
les priorités que nous avons identifiés
c'est d'abord la mobilité nous
investirons sur un plan routes c'est la
sécurité
la région doit s'impliquer et nous
mettrons les moyens nécessaires pour
vous protéger
tous ces investissements ils passeront
par une meilleure gestion
nous n'engagerons pas de nouvelles
dépenses sans avoir fait des économies
auparavant notre région a besoin
d'organiser la proximité avec tous ces
territoires
on fera une addition c'est fini le temps
de la fusion nous souhaitons que les 12
départements fasse partie d'une même
entité
les services du conseil régional seront
dorénavant présent dans tous les
départements
chaque département sera représentée par
un ou une vice présidente en charge de
ce territoire
les budgets seront déconcentrés ils
seront confiés en partie aux acteurs
locaux
la proximité sera au coeur de notre
action
aucun territoire de doigté ah bon
et je lutterai avec toutes celles et
tous ceux qui m'accompagnent contre la
fracture territoriale et la campagne
électorale s'engage pour le mois de juin
avec le 20 et le 27 juin
ce moment de rendez vous démocratique et
malgré toutes ces contraintes il trop
pouvoir continuer à exprimer nos besoins
nos projets écouter partager et ouvrir
une nouvelle page sur la région
[Musique]